Hello everybody. This is Dr. Conner. Welcome to another live webinar. We have a bunch of questions
that people have submitted and then we'll open it up for questions of the rest of the people
that are on here. So let's jump in, understand. Also when I answer these questions, I may answer
some questions without getting into that question. So I'm not afraid to show my ignorance to anybody
and I'm not afraid to stay within our boundaries or we can do legally too. So just understand
that I'll explain that as we go. I have a chronic line with multiple co-infections. Have you had
success treating this type of patient? I've recently experienced some digestive distress since you don't
see people in your office. Do you practice kinesiology virtually? If so, do you feel it's as accurate?
Helping a patient to heal. So first, I'll address that part. Yes, I do think
distance kinesiology is just as accurate as helping a person
in the office and it can be even better because it does take out some of the
maybe preexisting biases you're talking to a person and such. So I think it actually can be
more accurate. Of course, kinesiology is a technique that is basically an art form. And you
I think, firstly, you want to go to somebody who's praying over your situation and your cheek swab
as you do it. That's just my belief. So have I treated people with chronic life disease? I believe
that just about every chronic life disease is not just Borrelia. Borrelia burgdorfia is the bacteria
that's technically responsible for life disease, but it has multiple co-infections that go along with it.
Really, when you see somebody with chronic life, they have multiple co-infections. So it's just
is what it is. We used to see 100,000 patients over the years of helping people with dealing with
chronic life, and I'm not exaggerating. We've had a lot of success, but the success depends on
multiple factors. It depends on how far the patient is willing to go and do the things that they
need to deal with. And I explained a lot of this on the live course. Now our live course, we just
dropped the prices of our course for a period of time to literally one third the cost. So it's only
$107 for the live course. It's super cheap to find out. Some of the information that I'm going to
tell you right now, but you have to deal with other, it's not about everybody thinks they have live
and multiple co-infections. It's all about killing those things. That's a small component of what
you have to deal with. You have to deal with what is stimulating and immune response. You may have
had live and multiple co-infections that you have to find out, is it still an active infection?
Most of the time with chronic life and co-infections, it's not an active infection anymore. You're
dealing with the damage that it's been done. Many times, neurologically, upper motor,
there are brain type issues that it's caused inflammation of the brain and it's damaged by
curglio cells. And that's what you're really dealing with. Second thing that you're dealing with
any chronic disease, chronic life included, is that you're dealing with antibodies to self-dissue.
It's moved to the point of an autoimmune disease. You've created antibodies to self-dissue.
Once you do that, now it's really not the live you're dealing with. It's the autoimmune disease
you're dealing with. That's a whole other ball of wax. The chronic life course is really good.
The new course that I just launched is the chronic disease and autoimmune disease course.
It is even better. I probably recommend that one. That's where you're really digging to dealing
testing for antibodies, testing the immune system in a way that you just can't do any other.
You just really need to look at some deep things on the immune response to be able to deal with this.
Yes, we've had really good success with people over the years with chronic lung disease.
Looking for guidance with stage four, prostate cancer, particularly diet and supplements.
So with any metastatic cancer, it's a little bit different than just the primary cancer.
So with prostate cancer, there are some specific nutrients that you want to look at
that can be beneficial. With stage four, it really depends on one of their care that you've done.
If you're doing currently doing antigen deprivation therapy, I mean, a drug that's getting rid of
your testosterone, then you do want to add some very specific things back. Andrographis
is the thing that you want to make sure that you're adding or a nutritional herb if you're
on antigen deprivation therapy. I do have a blog post about that if you go back to our website
and search prostate cancer. The blog you'll see my article about that in some specific
nutrient that you want to look at. So as far as diet and supplements, you can look at our blog
under prostate cancer and you can search that. I highly recommend if you're a person that's listening
to this and you have cancer and hey, I maybe financially can't afford to get a rifle, you can't afford
to do our full program or anything, go and spend a few hundred dollars enjoying the stop fighting
cancer course. Again, it's one of the courses that we dropped to a hundred ninety seven dollars
for a limited time. I know the hollow word, I keep it at that, but it's well, it's worth 10 times
that much. You really should look at that course and dig into that. On that course, I have different
protocols for every different cancer. So that will give you some specifics. As far as diet with
any cancer, I can say overall, the most common thing that can drive a cancer, people say sugar. Yes,
of course, everybody should be on a low sugar, a low simple sugar diet, but dairy is the more overlooked
one, dairy, cow's milk, goat's milk, has nutrients in it to make a baby cow or maybe goat grow fast
into a very big cow and a very big goat. Those are growth factors that are in all dairy products,
not eggs, eggs aren't dairy, that's from a chicken. It is coming out of an utter can has growth factors
and that's one thing that you should stay away from. In somewhat used things like the rice machine
or inferensadas or PEMF, if you're on a mutal modulary drugs or a model,
modal antibodies for cancer, does it interfere with the effectiveness of the cancer drugs?
So the rice machine does not, and I would say that PEMF does not interfere with those drugs.
Of course, I'm not a pharmacist, so if I take that into consideration,
but the frequencies are not going to interfere with the drugs.
Inferensadas might be, so anything that you're going to do to, if you're on a medication for
a cancer and you're increasing your ability to detoxify, and that's why you would do it in
inferensada, it can decrease the effectiveness of the drug because you will increase the
rate of detoxification of that drug. So that I would ask, I would talk to your doctor about your
oncologist about doing sodas or coffee animals or doing heavy detox nutrients when you're on a
specific drug for cancer, you'd better need to talk to them about that. The rice machine in
the PEMF, no, you could do that. If you're running rife frequencies for cancer along with your
cancer drugs, there's no problem. PEMF is stimulating cell membrane potential, increasing the charge
of the cell membrane, decreasing pain. So that's not going to interfere with the drugs.
Any of these kinds of drugs, so no. I feel that the primary focus of my line,
Bartonella, Babicia infection is my head, including brain, eyes, and jaw. For example, I recently had
a tooth extracted, left side of jaw, and the lab tests followed the tooth to be infected with all three
of these things. In addition, I often feel the presence of something too small to see in my left eye.
Is there any way of determining where a line, Bartonella, Babicia infection may be localized?
Is it safe to hold the rife electrodes near the head when running a frequency treatment?
Well, first I'll address the last part of this question. Is it safe to hold the rife electrode? So I'm
not sure what rife machine you're using. So if you're using one that has electrodes instead of a
bulb and using light frequency, there's just a lot less efficacy of that. So
the rife machine that we use uses light frequency, and yes, you could put the bulb up next to your
head. You could put it up by your eye. There's no harm in doing anything like that.
If you're using a rife machine that's using pads, you're really using electrical frequency.
And no, you should not put that up by your head. So the general rule of thumb with any electrical
frequency like a PEMF tens unit rife pads is you've got to be careful using it by your head.
Now, I know that you can use electrical frequency on your head. In fact, there's the PEMF
devices that are specifically designed to use out your head for astrocytoma and glial blastoma.
But that's somebody professionally is helping you with that. So I would be careful about putting
up towards your head if you're if you have pads, it's really electrical frequency machine, not a
light frequency machine. Hi, off of your presence and something too small to see of my left eye,
is there any way of determining where the localized infection is?
Not through any lab testing that's out there. Is there a way to test where it's located?
The only way you can do is take a tissue sample and test that tissue sample. There's no labs that
are doing that for life that I know off right now. So I did say that in a previous question that
often chronic Lyme, chronic disease, chronic toxicity issues, chronic mold issues can end up
causing what's called an upper motor neuron lesion or issues with the brain, meaning that
if it crosses the blood brain barrier, it can damage neurons, it can damage
tissue in the brain. If it damages the immune cell in the brain, it's called the microglial cell,
but damages that microglial cell. And I say if because it's very common that that happens,
that microglial cell is called a primed microglial cell. And then that primed microglial cell
can sit in two different states. One of those states is that it's just spewed out in laboratory
chemical patterns, these inflammatory chemicals are called cytokines. So it's just sitting in this
in this prime state that's feeling and kicking out inflammation at all times. That's the
problem with damaged microglial or primed microglial cells. It's not a common at Lyme, mold,
heavy metal toxicity, toxicity to vaccinations, toxicity to other bio-toxins can cause microglial
primed, also composed of cuss of syndrome, that's where most of the research comes from.
So that is an issue that needs to be dealt with. So that's a whole other piece. I do have a video
a neuroinflammation that talks about explains microglial primate that could be beneficial.
That's where people with Lyme think, well, I got to kill the Lyme and they can actually do more damage
than good. So you want to test for those things. You also want to test more of the next
worst step in brain issue and inflammation. The brain is you can end up developing antibodies
to a neuronal tissue. There is a test that you can test for that. It's called the Cyrex Array 7x,
which is the best test for neuronal antibodies. That will give you a really good picture of exactly
what's going on in the brain. For a lot of our members, it's just like, oh my gosh, I thought I was
going crazy. Now I know why I have these issues and now at least I can safely work through them.
Can't magically make those things go away once those things exist. There's argument whether they'll
ever go away, but you can help manage that. And that is just a lifetime lifestyle, lifestyle changes
in the process. What is the best way to deal with metastasized testicular cancer in general? Well,
there isn't a really general way to deal with any metastasized cancer, whether it's metastasized from
testicular cancer, ovary cancer, colon cancer. You do have to manage that area that it's metastasized
to. Remember, if you have testicular cancer and metastasized to the liver, it's not liver cancer,
it's testicular cancer in the liver. Most college spot for testicular cancer to metastasized
the bone and the lumbar spine and the pelvis. It's not bone cancer, it's still testicular cancer.
So you still have to deal with it the way you should be dealing with the primary cancer.
And if you're using standards of care, they're going to be using chemotherapy and radiation.
If you're not using standards of care, my opinion is you absolutely better be using the
right machine and nutrition, specific nutrition and diet. You should get tested for that.
That's looking to our stop by the cancer course or old membership to really dig into that.
If you have metastasis to the bone, you have to deal with that because if you have bone that has
cancer in it, it's 99% of the time metastatic cancer to bone will be lytic, which means it'll be
eating away or eroding the bone. So you'll lose bone density. If it's a weight-bearing bone like
your lumbar spine, you can end up with what's called a pathological fracture. So even if persons like
totally against standards of care, I don't want to go down that route. I recommend people do
consult with a radiation oncologist because you want to kill the cancer in the area. That's where
radiation could really shine. So doing radiation specifically to that, you know, L2
vertebral body can kill the cancer and it can save the bone and save the world of hurt from
a pathological fracture. What can I do? Same person asked this question about very high calcium
creatine levels, resulting from metastatic testicular cancer to the lymph nodes. I'll tell you right now
very high calcium blood calcium levels is not a side of testicular cancer to the lip builds. It's
a side of metastatic cancer of any kind to the bone. So if you have high blood calcium levels
and other side of metastasis is the bone is high blood alcohol and phosphatase levels.
If you have high blood calcium level, it's coming from the bone. So you do well to look at that.
Created is going to be coming from the liver and the muscle. But excuse me, the kidney and the
muscle doesn't mean it's metastasized kidney but it's the way it's processed through the kidney.
You're going to have high creatine levels. But high blood calcium is a side that you have metastasis
to the bone. You better be looking for that, making sure that you're going to CT scan
and a PET scan to get proper analysis of exactly what's going on and then go back to that last question
and I addressed make sure that you address that in the bone if it's in a weight-barried
bone especially. How can I keep healthy since I have had chemo and now I am on an estrogen blocker?
What kind of nutrition or meals should I consume? How can I and my diet prevent new cells from forming?
Well, that's a lot of education that needs to be done there. I mean,
you know, you could at the very least download the first chapter by stop fighting cancer book
on our website that's free. The next step is to buy the stop fighting cancer book and read that.
I know it's a mouthful or it's a lot of head space 600 pages but you need to start educated
some things that can drive cancer. I mentioned earlier if this person I don't know who it is
to ask the question but that definitely dairy definitely sugar you want to decrease the
consumption of those don't make it a religion but you need to decrease this consumption of those
things. Cancer can be fed through glycolysis primarily and that's where you hear about cancer
feeds on sugar but not always. Some cancers can be fed through amino acids and typically glutamate
and methionate so you know a keto diet is not right for everybody. Keto decreases blood sugar and
helps your body feed mainly off of ketones but it's typically very high in animal protein
and it is very high in glutamated with iodine. If your cancer has fed on that then you are
basically feeding the cancer. So there's no perfect way to tell that if you're a full member we do
cheek swab testing to find that out but in general you should stay away from dairy you should stay away
from sugar just and eat a moderate diet should everybody go on a plant-based diet and not eat animal
protein. I know I don't think so I don't think that's healthy especially if you have genetic
considerations through with the the thyroid pathway you're going to feel way worse you know you're
going to feel you're going to be much less healthy being on a plant-based diet so this
be careful of fan diets like that just because it's real big in you know today's society be
plant-based don't think that that's good for you so it can be good for you but it can be really bad
for you so you know without getting tested just balance is best and if you're on an estrogen blocker
you know you don't want to be added anything to your diet that's going to feed estrogen so you
want to make sure you're staying away from soy products and things like that be careful of BPAs
and plastics anything that's going to increase exogenous estrogens as well also make sure you're
taking if you're on an estrogen blocker you really should be on a binder as well like
charcoal sodium alginate of fumeic acid fumeic acid those kind of things that will bind things that
they've got estrogen is the number one thing that's reabsorbed in your large intestine so
I talk about different binders in all my courses so that's something to look at too.
Okay that was the last submitted question if you have a question you can unmute yourself and
verbalize your question or you can ask it in the chat um we had a few minutes left so feel
free to jump in. If a person was facing uterine cancer would you recommend removal of the uterus?
Well that's one of those questions I can't legally answer so that's a question you're going to have
to discuss with your surgeon and your oncologist I can tell a person to remove their uterus or not
certainly if a person is of age that um hey I'm not going to be used by uterus I don't want to have
anymore children um re so removing the uterus with uterine cancer is a process what it's called a
surgery that's called debulking so it's the same thing with um you know you know remove my prostate
or I get to remove my breast because I have breast cancer um in one sense it makes a lot of sense
you're removing that organ you're getting your the cancer if it's contained to the organ you're
removing the whole thing the chance of survival just think about it makes sense it goes way up
because you're debulking the cancer then if you do a bunch of natural things to help because
definitely by the time a person has diagnosed cancer they have given off lots of circulating tumor
cells so those circulating tumor cells are cancer stem cells that are just circulating through the body
they're not yet quote unquote cancer cells they're just looking for a whole looking for a place to
set up home and raise a family that's what's called metastasis so just because you deboke a cancer
just because I do a double mastectomy does not mean that I'm in the clear and I'm never going to have
metastasis down the road it doesn't it statistically it doesn't so you but it still can be the smartest
idea so I mean just think about if I could remove the mass and so my immune system doesn't have to fight
against try to destroy this cancer this growing mass if I could have surgery to debulk the cancer
that I can build up my immune system to kill at ease circulating tumor cells and then build my
immune system so they never get a chance to grow and such so it does make sense so I can't answer whether
you should do that or not but I can walk you through just like the logic of that genetics course will
this help me understand what supplements a diet to use and not to use already had a genetic profile
done so if you just get the genetics course so quite honestly nobody just buys the genetic course
so if you had your genetics done somewhere else and you're just gonna you just want to learn more
about genetics well then do the genetics course but no if you have had your genetics done somewhere
else and you just get the genetics course it'll give you some ideas but you're gonna have to formulate
that yourself you're not gonna get a plan for us the genetics course is included with
if person does their full genetics with us then it really helps them understand my recommendations
and why I recommended it and it is based upon the genetic profile that we use which is the I think
the most comprehensive genetic profile that exists today so if you had your genetics done somewhere
else and you just want to learn more about it sir take the course I just don't want you to be disappointed
you're not gonna get a specific protocol from us I have diagnosed with CCIS stage one
the treatment is lumpectomy radiation estrogen blocker and we're reluctant to do the radiation
and drugs are there good options again I can't tell you to do or not to do medical procedure
but there are there are other options you certainly are on this call because you try to explore it
the next step again would be to you know read my book and other books that are out there
and you'll see that there's a lot of women that decided not to go down and all there's a lot of
women that decided to do some things but not everything we have a lot of members that are
that category they might have done some medical intervention and they decided to stop and they
want to do all that show from here or put it off as long as they can and so there are other good
options and then the next step beyond reading books would be to join the stop by the cancer course
um that would be a lot of good information and videos and therefore your tool
can you discuss the use of binders a bit how do you keep binders from binding the supplements
you're taking so typically you don't have that problem with binders binders are not gonna
specifically grab on to curcumin and pull it out of your body um so that's that's really not an
issue um can a person take too many binders taking too much charcoal or too much humic acid
yeah you can take too much of anything but um you know if you just stay to on the bottle like our
product called clear binder it's actually called phase 5 clear binder because I talk about bind
need in the detoxification course so the seven phases of detoxification maybe that'd be a good book
to get that some amazon you could download it on our website and phase five is binding stuff that's
in the gut that's so you don't reabsorb it um so just if you took like our clear binder phase five
clear binder you just took it just followed what's on the bottle I think it's two or three a day
you're going to be fine it's not going to be binding supplements so I wouldn't be concerned about that
explain the difference between a saliva test and a urine test for hormone testing which is more
accurate or best for determining breast cancer treatment well either one's gonna determine treatment
but the urine test is far more superior don't even do don't even think about doing a saliva test
when you're talking about estrogen progesterone testosterone and all the um metabolites of that
so the dutch test is the most accurate test out there and I like the precision duck duck test
we have it on our store if you want to order it you can't it's a urine test that you do at home
the one we use does have a saliva component but that's measuring cortisol not measuring
the estrogen progesterone or the antigens so that's that test so is it to help determine
breast cancer treatment well I guess yes and no if you have an elevated four hydroxy estero
16 hydroxy estero you're looking at methylated esteroids yes if those are elevated you certainly
want to get on if you're gonna go naturally you want to get on you know natural aromatic inhibitors
which is dim and icy three and uh so flora's eye and all sorts of things like that and I have multiple
blog posts on that so you can look at natural or you could just search our blog for
aromatase and that will come up um but you don't want to do those things anyway so um like if
person became a member of ours and they're like oh should I do a Dutch test right away
no you don't really need you're we're gonna do those things anyway so we have a lot of people that
choose to do a Dutch test because they want to see the balance of their hormones and by the time we do
the Dutch test their their quote-unquote bad estrogens aren't way down so but I've seen that literally a
hundred times so I don't recommend that people spend the money on the Dutch test really because of
that because we're gonna be doing so many things to lower the bad estrogen levels down that it would
they work so we don't need to do a Dutch test but certainly can we have people that do because
they're curious so um and I'd love to look at the test anyhow so will you please comment on multiple
bioloma what successes or failures have you experienced um again we can't say successes or failures
we're an alternative cancer support center we are don't treat cancer so if you call us and say what's
your success rate that's the answer you're gonna get and it's not just from legal mumbo jumbo I mean
we treat the person not the disease so and and we don't treat cancer we don't diagnose we don't we don't
treat cancer at all so um we've had a lot of people with multiple bioloma that have done real well
most of our members with multiple bioloma have coupled it with standards of care as well
um multiple bioloma could be in what's called a smoldering phase where it's kind of in a state of
quiet remission and I think with natural methods not just ours but all sorts of natural methods you
could prolong the smoldering phase and give a person a much better quality of life I know there's
oncologists that try to be conservative with their treatment most oncologists today are very
aggressive with multiple bioloma they'll put them on the chemotherapy drugs or like ever and
it doesn't make you feel good it's got a whole bunch of side effects and a lot of patients don't
want to be on it so if they can couple you know treatment with natural ways so that they can cycle on
and off those things and they're constantly looking at their numbers because multiple bioloma is
easily easily monitored through measuring your blood levels so you can see hey I'm still
hanging in there I'm not going to go back on the drug again for a little while and so you could
that's the way we've had you've helped people through multiple bioloma and we have a number of
people with that right now what's different between rife frequencies that come with the true rife
and the ones that you create well the ones that we create are specific to the person in specific to
whatever the person's diagnosis is so if somebody calls us and say hey I just I want to buy a rife
okay do you have a disease or a diagnosis no I just want to buy a rife for my family
and just run it for the kids and stuff and well then just go to true rife and just buy it for true rife
but they call us and say no I have you know colon cancer well then certainly you know it's
better to get a specific program that's for you for your disease that you could run on we write
programs for cancer programs for overnight use or or online programs for overnight use
that a person could use and you get our frequency course with it and everything so it's better
we're not trying to sell people stuff so if they don't need us and my programming to buy all
me and just go to true rife and buy it it's cheaper so you know we just want what's best for you
get rife frequencies they use diagnostically wow that's a great question easy answer though
the answer is no so there are machines out there that you might go to the practitioner and you put
your hand on a little cradle and it scans your hand for frequencies and the practitioner may say
hey the frequency for parasites came up for the frequency for heavy metals came up for it
so they might then go the next step which I think is wrong and say this means you have this parasite
sorry if you scan yourself with a rife with any frequency device and you get what's called a
hit of that frequency it does not mean you have that disease you that is malpractice I'm sorry
but it's just wrong so it's your you means you have a hit on that frequency and you it might be good
that you ran that frequency because it can be helpful but it does not equate to a diagnosis so
we get people come to us and say that all the time you know that oh I went to my thatcher path
they did this test and there's a whole bunch of different machines out there that do that test and
gave me this read out and said that I have Candida again well okay that does not mean you have Candida
you get that that is not a diagnostic test for Candida that means that you might have a hit on a
Candida frequency but there could have been other reasons why you even had that hit that had nothing
to do with Candida lots of reasons they will go to it now but that is not diagnostic so you do not
use rife frequencies diagnostically and I know some practitioners disagree with me but
I just don't take it wrong with that so no question oh okay I missed a question there are there
certain supplements you could recommend to take with the rife machine to help take toxins out
um really uh the the honest answer that question is you really need to read my seven phases of detox
book um or go the next step and and buy the course my seven phases of detox because that question
carries danger in it so most people think the way I think you're thinking like I want a detox so
what supplements can I take to help pull toxins out of my body logical question right but
that's a dangerous question because you're if you start taking if I answered that question said
well yeah you should use some key laders that key laders pull toxins out of your tissues
huge danger in that you start pulling toxins out of your tissues that's what I call phase zero
detoxification pathway is you have toxins in your cells that's what's the cause of cancer most of time
you have toxins in your extracellular spaces you have toxins that flow through your bloodstream
after exposure and the idea is to get those out of your body but your body has a way of doing it that
blood has to go through your liver that's how you get rid of anything so even if you start taking a
key later which is substance like DMSA and EDTA and other key laders even mild key laders like
cilantro and things like that you start taking those things well that makes sense my my practitioner
told me to start taking these because I my test showed my hair analysis showed heavy metal toxins
hugely dangerous if you lest you're dealing with downstream effects of detoxification so you start
pulling stuff out of the tissue and your liver can't handle that all that's going to do is circulate
around and be deposited somewhere else in your body and make you sicker second worst case scenario is
your liver is able to handle that and and it becomes more toxic and overborn is the liver and causes
liver issues third case case scenario let's say if your liver pathways are doing really well and open
it could overwhelm your gallbladder and and affect your bile and your bile flow and your
bile duct and that can be a cause of you know worst case scenario cancer there and then downstream so
you have to go back to the understand the seven phases of detoxification phase six is where you've
got to start how are your bowel movements or you have a daily bowel movements more than one bowel
are you getting out everything that's on the inside that's a huge thing that's where you've got to start
then phase five is are you grabbing on to toxins in the colon so anything that your liver works so
blasted hard to get rid of and dump into the small intestine that you're not reabsorbing along the way
because you have a damaged got wall called leaking got syndrome did you deal with that yet if you have
a dealt with that yet and you're not taking binders to make sure you're not reabsorbing things you have no
business keylating stuff on tissues then phase four is have you supported the bile the bile duct
and the gallbladder hugely important because if you got stasis in the gallbladder you could end up with
major gallstone issues if you start with chelation then you got to go to phase three two and one that's
in the liver and the only proper way to assess that is through genetics and once you look at your
cytokine people are 50 pathways your pond one pathways and your net pathways and such and your
glutathione pathways and you start supporting those after you supported six five four then you're
supporting three two one now you can start keylating stuff out of the tissue but it was more than you
probably wanted an answer but it's the right answer and you can you know look at my seven phase of
detox book to get more detail on that if you want to dig into the course you can do that as well
any other questions if you're on an estrogen block or should
experience cycle symptoms is so what can be done to reduce that if you're on an estrogen blocker
you are going to go through you know metapause so even if you're in metapause you're going to go
through a deeper metapause so even in metapause you're still making estrogen and progesterone
maybe not at all from the ovaries but you will still your your your adrenal glands still make estrogen
and progesterone even if you had your ovaries removed and that's what keeps semi-level horrible balance
in your body if you're on an estrogen blocker you're going to lose all your estrogens and you're
going to go through a deeper metapause and there's really nothing you can if you do something about
that like you know take supplement with soy or you know that's going to help balance hormones and
such you could actually stimulate your drills to create more as you're really kind of
you're negating the effects of the estrogen blocker so that's what a lot of women don't like
if they're uh if they have you're or too positive cancer and they go on a orbitase inhibitor they feel
horrible and that's never one resource what the big reasons why people call our office they don't
want to do the medical procedure anymore I want to do a natural procedure which none of the natural
orbitase inhibitors are going to give you put you into a basically uh drug-induced
um you know complete complete loss of estrogens so um it's hard you know if people we have people
that are on a orbitase inhibitors and they're like oh my gosh I got the worst hot glasses I have the
worst symptoms what can I do about it well that means it's working there's not really anything you could
really know about that um you know they are going well can I take maca can I do a bunch of adaptogens
can I yeah but you just got to be careful that you don't start stimulating more estrogen production
that's why you're decreasing the side effects of the lack of estrogen do you offer a package that is
not include the purchase of the right person already has a right but need special programming
you can call the office about that um I'm not actually completely sure about that so call the office
about that all right I think we're going to call it a night thanks everybody for being on the night
and um I um um we'll um probably be doing another one of these next month and uh we'll let you know
it'll be up on the website so all right know that I'm praying for you I love you all and um
uh know that god has you it is hand to matter what struggle you're going through all right bye bye